good morning Hank it's Wednesday it
actually no actually does Wednesday I
was going to say it's actually Tuesday
and I'm recording this on Tuesday night
because I'm about to take a plane to
London and I'm packing and I'm like sort
of up in the middle of the night I'm
gonna say it was actually Tuesday night
but actually it is Wednesday now and
it's like 2:30 in the morning and I am
recording my video because I am NOT
going to get punished if you're
expecting anything that's even remotely
as complicated as as you saw on Friday
what I need you to do is now to reach
into your tube screens and you just turn
your expectation meters down keep
churning down down and down because
there's no such nonsense this week
things are just crazy here they're nuts
so I want to thank you all because I've
been reading your comments on the last
video and they are really really great
and a lot of people had a lot of
constructive criticism about things like
the incredibly apocalyptic lighting and
things like that and I'm trying to fix
that this week and I hope it's a lot
better but I did notice in reading
through the comments that 80% of the
comments contained one thing in common
that I realized is the thing that
YouTube has in common with little baby
henry green namely that you are both
very very interested in boobs the most
common comment was oh my god I didn't
know John Green had boob did you know
John Green had boobs oh my god John
Green has boobs when did John Green get
oh you guys the man just had a baby come
on you got to expect that so I was in
the New York Times this week my picture
was in it and it turns out I was
something like in the front global page
or whatever and it was totally this
weird fluky thing that happened and I
feel like I really have to kind of
explain you see earlier sort of like at
the end of last year I convinced my
publisher that it would be a really
really awesome idea to give away free
ebooks of my book sweet scarlet for it
like a couple weeks whatever we could
possibly manage because I think that
there's a huge benefit to giving away
free books and materials whenever
possible because like John I think the
coming revolution of e-books and all
these other ways that books can be
delivered and distributed to people it's
going to radically change the way that
we read and we have to embrace it
because if all the rumors are true then
today Apple will be announcing the Apple
tablet and not since the time of Moses
has you might've been this excited about
the appearance of a tablet I myself I'm
pretty excited about it I'm probably
going to buy one but of course I'm
gonna buy one on the first day because
you know whenever they put these new
products out there's always something
wrong with them like they accidentally
include a button that blows up the moon
or something and also free books are
kind of good you know like those big
buildings where they keep them and
people can go in and check them out and
like read them for no cost what are they
called again oh right libraries the
building blocks of society there's all
kinds of good stuff going on there
anyway I had all these really really
good ideas but then something went
terribly terribly wrong in the middle of
the interview and do you want to know
why because in the middle of the
interview I got distracted because I
looked over and I noticed my Rob
Pattinson annual from 2010 never make a
Rob Pattinson joke to the New York Times
because no matter what else you say they
will only quote you on the Rob Pattinson
job no matter what it is you were
talking about I'd been warned about this
people told me that whenever you do an
interview no matter what it is you stay
you can say like purely brilliant things
for an hour they will only quote you on
the stupidest thing you say and this
turns out to be 100% true because I have
to wrap this up really quickly like
they're my suitcases behind me and and I
got a book do I'm finishing 13 little
blonde poops to it I got scarlet fever
coming out on Monday and there's a
craziness going on I want to quickly
address the problem of what Hank should
name his dog and I think that the answer
has already been clearly provided by
YouTube and all of you have spoken and
I've asked you and the conclusion is the
Hank that you should name your dog boobs
because seriously how awesome would it
be to have a dog named boobs cuz you
could get away with like tons of stuff
you could go in the park and be like
c'mere boob who's a good bunch of boobs
such boobs look for boobs boobs anyone
seen boobs you can do so much if you
don't name your dog boobs I think you're
gonna be letting nerdfighteria down and
that's all I had to say about that
matter Hank Hank I'll see you on Friday